[Music]
you look fantastic
don't you do you you look really good
mother for a mother I think I'm hanging
in there I'm almost 40 Oh what what
incredible I know I'd say you look more
than fantastic there is some go-go
dancers or so what are you talking about
Andi and I are all the sex anybody needs
horn section that was horrifying
congratulations on your book and the
book of course about growing up Catholic
something I know a little bit about yes
or yes we converted when I was eight
from Judaism you say that Jesus in this
book you say Jesus was your Justin
Bieber and I don't know what you mean by
that
you know my mom I come from a very
strict Irish Catholic family and my mom
really wouldn't let us have like Fonzie
posters that was like who's hot in my
era yeah on the wall so we had we were
loud the Pope or Jesus and Jesus you
know had many different types of looks
he had like the suffering Jesus and the
sacred burning heart Jesus yeah hippy
Jesus so I had the hippy one of my wall
and I I became hot for Jesus that is so
strange I don't know well first of all I
didn't even know you could get a Jesus
poster anywhere it's basic what 7-eleven
back in the day like in your
neighborhood our Catholic neighborhood
was so I'm go to 7-eleven and buy a
Jesus poster and so it sounds like it's
a Jesus with like feathered back hair
right those baby blue eyes and you know
you need in puberty you're growing up
you're like oh my god Jesus is kind of
hot so he was definitely my beeper so
other kids had pop stars on the wall you
had Jesus but it was a little bit
confronting because of course at that
age as I started getting to puberty I
what happened there do you have a small
stroke what happened
you are so repressed you've no idea
Super Dave Mirra pressed it brought one
particular time my boyfriend up to my
room and we were dry humping his one
wood at that age and we're talking about
here 12:04 me that would be 34 you know
like going through the action and going
you have to stop because Jesus is
looking at us right now and most
Catholics gonna be like you're ever in
the house that give those posters are
those you know religious figures they
seem like they're staring at you when
you're doing ma yeah sure I'd be like oh
my god Jesus is staring at me right now
wait there was a Jesus poster in your
shower yeah for most of the Pope in the
bathroom but um you know I told my work
for the stop dry humping me because
Jesus is staring at us and there was a
poster of Cindy I'm gonna like a
magazine of Cindy Lauper on the counter
so I ripped it off and taped it on
Jesus's face well that's just really
confusing that that's true but then you
got a Cyndi Lauper with a flaming harp
is that right and then my mom walked in
and busted us mid dry-hump and saw Cyndi
Lauper's face on top of Jesus turd
screen and he ripped it off and when she
did it ripped off Jesus's eyes so I was
like
Jesus can't see what I'm doing anymore
now I'm assuming in your family nobody
talked about sex because you know I
still it's not discussed in my family
and we're all in our late 70s but sure
I mean masturbation what I I did not
touch myself I think until I was 21 but
how did this break into a dr. Drew
segment I mean I love it I really do I
think it's fascinating but what do you
mean you didn't touch yourself - I feel
like I should have dr. Drew glasses
tubby
we're gonna take a call right now
Tommy the teddy bear though was the one
that did all the work because you know
that your your I was taught you will
burn in hell if you go there or touch
anything so I just kind of rubbed every
my body on everything in the house
you rubbed your body up against a teddy
bear because you weren't allowed to
touch yourself yeah so tubby was gonna
burn in hell forever not me so then one
day came in from school swear swear to
God true story and my mom was having a
garage sale and she freaking sold tubby
after four years I'm like somebody has a
stinky pubescent puberty bear with a
giant smile on stage
[Applause]
god